all righty so today is the big tax
reform day it finally has passed through
Congress your taxes will go down the
Democrats moan in lamentation we will
talk about all that plus I sort of
face-planted Rosie O'Donnell on Twitter
and it's hilarious so we'll talk about
all of that I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
yes I am back from Florida where I had a
great time talking to the college
students over at TP USA one of my
favorite student groups and it was it
was a blast I also met Donald Trump jr.
which nice to meet you done as that was
kind of fun but I have a lot to talk
about today because a big news day and
it of course starts with this massive
tax reform package that is now passed
the Republican house and the Republican
Senate President Trump is set to sign
that into law formerly probably after
Christmas they have to work out a few
more kinks I think and then he's gonna
sign that into law so that as big I'm
going to discuss everything that is in
this tax reform package I'm going to
recount the entire saga in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so I had a
really good trip to Florida there was
one thing that did not go particularly
well that was my sleep pattern my sleep
pattern was a giant fail one of the
reasons that my sleep pattern was a
giant fail is because I did not have my
helix sleep mattress helix sleep offers
something that does not exist anywhere
else it is a mattress personalize your
unique preferences and sleeping style it
will not set you back thousands of
dollars go to helix sleep calm /ban you
take there
two to three minutes sleep quiz they ask
you sort of your body type do you like
something on your side or your stomach
do you want the mattress to be firm or
soft breathable or heat absorbent and
then they will build a custom mattress
for you it'll be the best thing that you
have ever slept on my wife in actually
had a more expensive mattress in our
room and we moved it out of our room in
favor of our helix sleep mattress it's
being recommended by all of the top
magazines out there your custom mattress
arrives directly to your door and you
it's in the box you unpack it it
inflates
and then it's ready to go and you can
try it for a hundred nights if you don't
love it they will pick it up and refund
it to you in full refund you the full
amount owed a helix sleep comm slash
Bennett right now helix sleep comm slash
Ben and you will get 50 bucks toward
your custom mattress that's helix sleep
calm / Ben for 50 bucks off your order
helix sleep calm / menus that / Ben also
so that they know that we sent you and
sleep better because this is one of
those things where you invest a little
bit of money in your mattress less than
you would if you went retail and and you
will end up making your life
significantly better okay so today
dawned amidst a cacophony of howling
dogs mourning their dead masters men
women children killed in a mass
senseless slaughter by the passage of
tax reform the Republicans just said
that they wanted lower taxes
Democrats knew the media knew that if
this tax reform package were to go
through then it would be like The
Walking Dead zombies would wander the
earth just dead bodies stacked up in
cars on the highways
that's exactly how it was this morning
traveling back from Florida you know I
was the only person on the plane I to
fly myself the airports were deserted
everyone was dead I don't even know
who's listening to this program now I
don't even know if there's anyone to
listen to this program Austin over there
is inanimate corpse just making this
show happen from behind the screen and
this is what they had warned about now
the amazing thing is that I didn't know
that everyone could be killed again
since everyone was killed by net
neutrality repeal a week ago but
apparently death can be died a thousand
times and so everyone's dead from that
neutrality repeal and repeal of the
Paris Accords and all the rest of it and
now everyone has died again so you know
I guess finally there's time for me to
read just like burgess Meredith and
Twilight Zone you know it's it's been
very weird inhabiting this afterlife
because it's so similar to regular life
the only good thing is that Justin
Bieber doesn't have any new good songs
in this afterlife lately so that's been
that's been excellent but otherwise it
seems very similar and I will admit that
now that I'm dead I feel a peculiar
desire to head over to Chicago and vote
Democrat which it had not occurred to me
before but suffice it to say this is me
being a sarcastic because not everyone
is dead no one died in fact in fact your
taxes just went down if you are 80% of
Americans your tax went down today so
here are the things you need to know
about this historic tax reform bill and
it really is historic okay it's historic
because it is a massive reduction in the
corporate tax ID everyone's focusing on
the individual tax ID the part that
really matters is the corporate tax
reform okay so you're gonna get a little
bittle bit of money back not
insignificant you'll get a little bit
money back on your taxes if you are in
the middle class the average tax cut the
average family how the average household
is supposed to receive according to the
Tax Policy Center a tax cut of about
1600 bucks in 2018 an average household
earning 100 million bucks or more what
see a tax decrease of approximately 70
grand
compared to 870 bucks for households
making 50 to 75 grand that's because
people at the upper end of the tax
spectrum are paying nearly all the net
taxes in the country it's not because
the Republicans just decided to benefit
the rich it's that if you reduce rates
for the rich they are getting back a lot
more money because they're making a lot
more money and they're paying a lot more
money okay this isn't the big
tax cut in history but it's not
insignificant the idiotic idea that
apparently 50% of Americans believe that
you're gonna pay more tax because of
this bill is just stupid and it's
because the media have been lying to you
the media been saying this is a
redistributionist bill from poor to rich
absolutely untrue now here's the thing
the individual tax decreases sunset okay
so in 2025 the individual tax decreases
are supposed to go away but in all
likelihood they're going to remain the
reason they're gonna remain is who
actually wants to vote openly for tax
increases Democrats are probably gonna
maintain those middle-class tax rates
the reason that Republicans had them
sunset in 2025 is because one of the
budget tricks that has to be done here
is if you wanted to pass in the Senate
with 51 votes which is how many votes it
got if you wanted to pass in the Senate
with that number of votes instead of 60
to kill a filibuster then the CBO the
Congressional Budget Office has to rule
that the bill will be deficit-neutral so
the bill is deficit neutral according to
the CBO that's because of some
gamesmanship by Republicans that's not
rare okay here's the thing about the
corporate tax rates and here's the case
no one's gonna make corporate tax rates
go down that means companies can afford
to give raises that they can afford to
actually create jobs and the early
evidence of this is today AT&T announced
that it would give a $1,000
across-the-board bonus to everyone
thanks to the tax decrease and now that
this corporate tax rate has been reduced
they will give $1,000 bonus to everyone
that's a pretty amazing thing
now some may say that this is a cynical
ploy by AT&T to basically give the Trump
administration a good headline so that
Trump will will allow the HNC Comcast
merger to go through I'm not gonna say
that that sounds right to me but it
sounds exactly right to me still the
corporate tax rate dropping is a good
thing for business and the proof that
it's a good thing for business is that
in every other country where the
corporate tax rate has been dropped
precipitously what you see is
significant GDP growth the most obvious
example is Island Ireland actually has a
12.5 percent corporate tax rate so it's
become a sort of business haven for
corporations that wanted to business
overseas and they've seen a high
sustained growth thanks to that healthy
business climate in 1995 they actually
had a corporate business tax of 40% they
dropped it to 12.5%
and they've seen 23% GDP GDP growth
since compared to 7.2 GDP growth from
1960 to 1995 over the course of 35 years
they saw 7.2 percent GDP growth then
they
moved the the corporate tax rate down
from 40 percent to 12.5 percent and over
the last 27 years they have seen a 23
percent increase in GDP so this has also
been seen in countries ranging from
Germany to Spain when you reduce the
corporate tax rate it makes it easier
for other countries if I'm perfect for
companies to invest in the United States
they no longer are trying to organize
his offshore companies there's also in
this bill a big increase in the child
tax credit that child tax credit is
truly a redistribution scheme he's a lot
of people who don't pay taxes are
getting the child tax credit but it's
backed by a lot of Republicans because
they think that the families with
children have higher expenses and we got
to give them benefits I am actually as
the father of two children I'm not
really in favor of the child tax credit
on a strictly libertarian viewpoint I
don't think the government should be
giving you incentives to behave in
certain ways and I don't think anybody
is having kids for the tax credit I
don't think it's just you know oh well
you know before I wasn't gonna have a
kid now I'm getting 2,000 bucks back I
suppose I'll have the child kids are a
lot more expensive than that the average
cost of a child from the time they're
born until the time that they leave the
house at 18 is hundreds of thousands of
dollars but still this is something that
looks good in the headlines for
Republicans that they're trying to help
out families that's why Marco Rubio
pushed it there are a few people who'll
be paying more in in income tax that
includes me which makes me sad a tax
reform includes reductions in tax
deductions for state and local taxes so
people in Heist tax states like
California they're reducing my taxes
through the tax rate but they're
increasing my taxes because the
deductions are not even close to what
I'm going to be paying in my state tax
in in the state of California plus the
mortgage interest deduction has been
decreased markedly you can now only take
a mortgage interest deduction up to
$750,000 alone in the state of
California pretty much everybody who
owns a home has a mortgage that is
bigger than that itemization has been
downsized so instead of you having to
itemize every deduction they've doubled
the standard deduction so a lot of
people no longer have to itemize because
you're only deducting you're only doing
itemized deductions if you want
deductions above and beyond the standard
deduction now the standard deduction has
been doubled so that means that itemized
deductions are probably going to go the
way the dodo burn for a lot of folks
that's great it means that you don't
have to hire an accountant you can now
fill out your taxes on the back of a
postcard you
individual mandate is gone so this is a
major win as well right the tax bill
uses the death of the individual mandate
to reduce deficits how why does it
reduce deficits when you get rid of the
individual mandate when people are
supposedly being forced to pay into the
system the reality is that because of
the individual mandate because you are
forced to go get health care people have
gone and registered with Medicaid that
costs millions and billions of dollars
to the federal government fewer people
are gonna register from Medicaid cuz
they're not mandated to do so that means
the bill goes down now is this entirely
a good thing well it would be entirely a
good thing just on the surface of it
right you no longer have the federal
government forcing you into a position
where you must must must do this
however it's not good for one reason
that I'll explain in just a moment and
the reason that the individual mandate
leaving may not be the world's greatest
thing is because if the individual
mandate goes away you have to fill the
gap for all of the sick people who are
still in the individual insurance market
right the way that we were filling that
before is we were basically forcing
young healthy people to buy insurance
and that was driving the rates down in
the individual insurance market they
were basically paying to compensate a
bunch of old sick people in the
individual insurance market those rates
are now likely to go up some and that
means that the federal government is
going to have to make a choice either
they're gonna have to remove the
Obamacare regulations which would be the
ideal or they're going to have to fill
in backfill the funding insurance
companies lose because of the individual
mandate that unfortunately seems like
the way the federal government is going
it seems like Republicans are gonna be
voting basically for a new it looks like
the Republicans are gonna be voting for
a new entitlement program which is not a
grand and glorious thing so I want to
give you the rest of what's in this
taxable but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
so despite the fact that the stock
market is soaring despite the fact that
the economy is going supremely well
despite all of that I think that it is
it is necessary to point out that the
economy can always tank at any time
right everybody thought the economy is
going gangbusters in early 2007 and then
it tanked on you one of the reasons that
you ought to diversify it ought to have
some money in precious metals is because
of the risk of an economic downturn
which could be brought about by anything
from a public event to a foreign policy
of it I'm not saying take your entire
portfolio and put it in gold that'd be
foolish but I am saying take some of
your money and put it in precious metals
when you choose to do that go to my
friends at Birch
golde group they have a long-standing
track record of continued success with
thousands of satisfied clients countless
five-star reviews and a plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau and right now
they're giving away a comprehensive 16
page kit showing how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA if
that's something you choose to do right
now if you're looking at Bitcoin and
saying wow bitcoin is doing really well
that's because bitcoin is basically a
controlled asset they're not making it
anymore bitcoin that's the whole purpose
of it gold basically performs the same
function in the global market to get
your no cost no obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash burn that's
birchgold.com slash Ben check it out ask
all your questions then when you're
ready to invest talk to my friends at
Birch cool comm slash bet okay so let's
talk about the rest of what's in this
bill so they're now opening the Anwar to
oil exploration the Anwar is not on
Rolla key it is the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge so there's a portion of
Alaska that has been ruled out of bounds
by the federal government for the last
couple of decades it should've been
opened up a long time ago the part that
they want to drill is very small it
leaves a small footprint and the idea
that it was going to destroy the
environment in Alaska is utterly untrue
supposedly their reserves under there
that are about the size of Saudi Arabia
possibly so drilling in the Anwar would
be good for America's domestic oil
reserves this is a good thing the one
bad the the worst thing about this bills
the deficits are gonna increase right
the Republicans have said that will grow
our way out of deficits that will be
true to a certain extent it won't be
true to the point where it'll cover for
for the for the government revenue hole
that's been blown in the budget but
that's why Republicans should be focused
on cutting now right Republicans should
actually use this opportunity to cut now
I know Republicans just want to win
elections but what that leads to is big
government at least to a battle between
big government Republicans and big
government Democrats and both of them
end up blowing up the deficit if
Republicans actually want to make a
difference they're gonna have to take up
another priority of speaker Ryan's and
that is Medicaid reform Medicare reform
block grants to States all these are
things that the Republicans are gonna
have to do okay so all of this said it's
a good I like this bill I think it's a
good bill it's not a perfect bill it has
things that I would change about it but
it is a fairly typical and very positive
Republican tax bill people have lost
their damn minds
they have gone absolutely insane over
this so yesterday at the Capitol in the
middle of the vote there was a group of
protesters
who started chanting about how the bill
was going to end in their imminent
demise the actual medicine is not
produced here it's produced in Ireland
because the chair has detected a
disturbance in the gallery in
contravention of the law and against the
rules of the house the sergeant-at-arms
will identify the person or persons
responsible and have them escorted from
the House chamber so these idiots are up
there shouting kill the bill don't kill
us and apparently one of them decided to
take off her top which I mean she
understand she's in Congress right like
in Congress like the same Congress that
houses half the sexual perverts in
America she just incentivized Congress
to pass a tax bill every single day I
didn't see a picture of the lady but I
assume that you know if she is of the
female persuasion and has breasts than
half the congressmen in the place are
excited about that that form of protest
that seems to be counterproductive but
kill the bill don't kill us I mean just
demonstrates the extent to which the
left has lost its might one of the
people who's lost her mind obviously is
Rosie O'Donnell she's not much of a mind
left to lose sadly but Rosie O'Donnell
tweeted this out she tweeted out so how
about this I promise to give two million
dollars to senator Susan Collins and two
million to Senator Jeff Flake if they
vote no no I will not kill Americans for
the sewer rich she mens right super but
she can't type it's suo ER rich DM me
Susan DM me Jeff no bleep two million
cash each it's like EE Cummings for the
mentally deficient
so well done there Rosie O'Donnell this
by the way is a technically under
federal law bribery so under 18 USC I
believe the actual statute is 18 USC 2
and 1b it says quote whoever directly or
indirectly corruptly gives offers or
promises anything of value to any public
official or person who has been selected
to be a public official or offers or
promises any public official or any
person who has been selected to be a
public official to give anything of
value to any other person or entity with
intents who influenced any official act
shall be fined under this title not more
than three times the monetary equivalent
of the thing of value which whichever is
greater or in prison for not more than
fifteen years or both and may be
disqualified from holding any office of
Honor
trustor profit under the united states
so she's openly offering four million
dollars to republican senators for them
to change their vote which is bribery
under federal law she's doing that in
front of apparently thirty two thousand
likes so that that you know I guess
she's must be willing to pay twelve
million dollars to the federal
government I said earlier if President
Trump tells jeff sessions to initiate a
prosecution against Rosie O'Donnell they
will begin carving his face into
Rushmore tomorrow I mean he will
immediately move to the list of the
nation's greatest presidents if he
initiates prosecution again still
against Rosie O'Donnell
for for bribery so I tweeted out half
jokingly this morning lock her up lock
her up and Rosie O'Donnell got mad and
she tweeted back at me suck my bleep Ben
which doesn't make sense for a variety
of reasons as far as I'm aware and so I
tweeted back at her you're already a
felon Rosie don't be a homophobic sexual
harasser - and then I followed it up
with hashtag me too so that that's that
is my a plus troll game right there
again that is that it's the the troll is
strong with me today I said Rosie
O'Donnell yeah just making a fool of
herself as always and she's not the only
one who's going nuts the Democrats of
course are going completely nuts as well
the House passed the act and Paul Ryan
brought out the giant gavel he brought
out the the enormous gamble I guess they
have this giant ceremonial gavel that
they bring out for important occasions
and also for sex parties and so Paul
Ryan dragged that sucker out of storage
when Nancy Pelosi stood there with the
giant gavel and she first became Speaker
and she had a bunch of children she had
an aborted standing around her he
brought that out of storage and he was
whacking that on the on the pan on the
on the podium as they passed it here was
the video of them passing this thing in
the house yesterday on this vote the
yeas are 227 and the nays are 203 the
conference report is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the table
[Applause]
okay so that is a big win for Paul Ryan
it's a big win for the house it's a big
win for the Republican Senate and it's a
big win for President Trump it is a big
win for president Trump without this win
he does not have a signature legislative
achievement his entire first year
without that win the biggest things that
he's done this year are just ask or such
and in the movement of the embassy to
Jerusalem and the filming of the
appellate judge I talked in the last
podcast about all of the things that I
think Trump has done right but this is a
signature achievement in his first year
and he needed one right for Obama he had
several he had the lilly Ledbetter Act
and then it took a year and a half but
he got Obamacare he had passed the
stimulus package which was really his
big achievement in his first year george
w bush passed tax cuts I believe in the
middle of year one so Trump needed this
he needed it pretty badly and he
deserves to be able to celebrate about
Paul Ryan says this is a profound change
to the tax system here's what he had to
say this is one the most important
pieces of legislation that Congress has
passed in decades to help the American
worker to help grow the American economy
this is profound change and this has
changed that is gonna put our country on
the right path okay so the Democrats of
course went completely nuts because
their basic belief system suggest that
you don't own your own money right that
any tax cut to you you keeping more of
your own money is actually theft from
the federal coffers and this just it
demonstrates the the genuine disconnect
as far as what Republicans and Democrats
think in terms of where your rights come
from the government the Democrats
believe that your rights come from
government your right to have property
is because the government has allowed
you to have property if it weren't for
the government allowing you to have
property you wouldn't have property
right this is the Elizabeth Warren
barack obama view that you didn't build
that right your property rights are
based on a government that makes those
property rights available to you the
Republican notion the conservative
founding notion is that property rights
predated government that government was
instituted in order to protect those
property rights and that if the
government violates those property
rights it has lost its raise on debt its
lids lost the reason for its existence
so you can see this gap in the way the
Democrats talk about this so Nancy
Pelosi went up there with a giant yellow
sign that says hashtag GOP tax scam and
says that raises taxes on 88 million
middle-class families that is a lie it
does not
taxes on 88 million middle class
families there is I don't know where the
hell they're getting that statistic but
there's no evidence whatsoever that that
is the case does 83 percent of the
benefit goes to the wealthiest 1% okay
that is because the wealthiest 1% are
paying a wildly disproportionate share
of the taxes and says it results in 13
million more uninsured Americans that's
a lie too because getting rid of the
individual insurance mandate what that
does it allows people to opt out you can
still buy insurance right you can still
go get covered by Medicaid tomorrow
right you can go tomorrow if you are
eligible for Medicaid you can go get
covered by Medicaid what it means is
that the vast majority of people are
gonna be dropping out don't want to
bother with doing these things and so
they haven't bothered to go buy
insurance and they shouldn't be forced
to but in any case here's Nancy Pelosi
saying that this is this tax plan is
theft how how is it theft i honest to
god I don't understand how it's tough
for me to keep more of my own money this
GOP tax scam cent is simply theft
monumental brazen theft from the
American middle class and from every
person who aspires to reach it the GOP
tax scam is not a vote for an investment
in growth or jobs is a vote to install a
permanent plutocracy in our nation
they'll be cheering that later okay
they'll be cheering the plutocracy later
the theft again the plutocracy is
centralized government stealing your
money and using it for whatever purpose
a nancy pelosi wants to put it to the
idea that it is a it is a theft for the
government to not take money out of my
pocket is it's beyond reasoning it's
beyond reasoning and that's not the only
dumb thing that Nancy Pelosi had to say
right Nancy Pelosi had to say something
even more dumb and here's what now Andy
here's the here's in one second I'm
gonna play you the incredibly stupid
thing that Nancy Pelosi had to say so
here it is Nancy Pelosi this clip 19
Nancy Pelosi says that not only is this
a is this a tax theft not only is it
creating plutocracy it betrays what the
founding fathers would have wanted it
does violence to the vision of our
founders it disrespects the sacrifice of
our men and women in uniform who are a
large part of our middle class and to
whom we owe a future worthy of their
sacrifice
and it portrays the future and betrays
the aspirations of our children and
betrays the future and betrays our past
the founding fathers does she understand
that the reason that we fought a
revolution is because no taxation
without representation it was literally
the slogan of the revolution is she
aware and one of the reasons people were
mad is because Britain kept putting
taxes on all of the imported goods right
would the Stamp Act and the tea acted
like she aware of anything remotely
related to American history here like
the founders would have hated our tax
regime the founders didn't even believe
in an income tax we had to pass a
constitutional amendment to allow an
income tax one of the worst
constitutional amendments in American
history right it's it by I would say
easily actually the worst constitutional
amendment American history even worse
than prohibition was the it was the
income tax but this is just it's beyond
it's beyond reason the Democrats have
made up an alternative history in the
United the United States in which Thomas
Jefferson and George Washington and John
Adams and James Madison and Alexander
Hamilton were all giant government
centralized government people which is
just patently insane you know that if
you listen to the show we go through a
federalist paper every Monday have we
yet come to the point where we say we
need a federal government to suck up all
the resources and redistribute them has
that ever come up in the Federalist
paper it has not nor will it ever even
gonna get through all 80 odd Federalist
Papers right she's not gonna happen so
she's not the only one saying dumb stuff
chuck schumer the the Senate Majority
Minority Leader still Minority Leader
thank God he says that the public knows
this bill is bad and here is where the
rubber hits the road we're gonna talk in
a second about whether this bill really
is bad for Republicans even though it is
a politically useful thing they don't
want to discuss it they don't want to
have it have sunlight shed on it they
don't want anyone to know what's in it
because it is so so bad and the public
knows it okay it is so so bad in the
public notice to the polls show that
this is wildly unpopular tax bill there
are a couple reasons for that one the
media are just awful the media are just
awful they their treatment of the tax
bill has been completely unfair the AP
branded headline after it passed saying
massive Republican tax giveaway to the
rich that was in their headline okay
that level of bias is just bizarre and
insane CNN plastered its front page
Joubert cnn.com with anti tax reform
messages it was all over the media that
this tax reform was the end of the world
that millions would die it was something
that we should all be deeply worried
over and deeply upset about none of that
was true it's why fifty percent of
Americans think their taxes are going up
even though their taxes are going to go
down so part of that is the media part
of it is that Republicans are
incompetent at pitching this thing you
know President Trump he gets credit for
passing this thing but it would be great
if the president would spend a fair bit
of time explaining for example why the
corporate tax rate needed to drop right
that would be really excellent I'd like
for him to tax honestly I would like for
him use Twitter for a good effect I'd
like for the president to tweet out the
European corporate tax rates and then
the American corporate tax rates because
the average European corporate tax rate
right now is eighteen point four three
percent we just brought our corporate
tax rate down to twenty one percent we
brought it down by 14 percent and it is
still higher than the average European
tax rate corporate tax rate President
Trump really should do a public
relations blitz a big victory for him so
now he should use all of the power that
he has to bring cameras to him to
discuss tax reform and use Twitter that
way right because otherwise you know we
don't need another fight with Lavar ball
but what we do need is a solid public
relations campaign and this is Trump
specialty Trump specialty is the PR
campaign it's what he is best at in life
so I'd love to see him put that to good
effect here to put that to good use that
I think would be an excellent thing so
I'd like to see the President of the
United States do that also
the Republicans kept pitching this thing
in terms of individual tax rates none of
them have ever bothered to explain why
corporate tax rates going down is better
and the reason corporate tax rates going
down is better is because that money can
now be used by the corporation to hire
more people to invest more to to pay
their workers more to give people raises
Republicans should be making that case
loudly and proudly and they should be
saying every Democrat opposed this your
taxes went down and every Democrat
opposed this but unfortunately the
Republicans have not done a good PR job
now the problem is this when you have an
unpopular bill and you pass it even if
it's good for Americans it's pretty rare
that an unpopular bill gets wildly more
popular over time that is not a that is
not a usual thing to happen Obamacare
was very unpopular when it passed it was
in net negative territory and there was
59 percent by one poll 59 percent of
Americans at the time of
passage of Obamacare disapproved of
Obamacare and it really never recovered
it was always an unpopular law the only
point of popularity came when
Republicans tried to get rid of it and
the media went on a full-out blitz but
it's pretty rare for a bill to get more
popular over time even if it does get
more popular it's not gonna be for front
of the public's imagination you make a
case for the bill well you're passing
the bill you don't make the case for the
bill after the bill has passed the
reason for that is it fades into
people's woodwork right mean you have
other things to worry about now this
week we're talking tax reform last week
we talked tax reform the week before
that we talked tax reform by the time
you pay your taxes you've probably
forgotten about tax reform you just
signed the check and you're done with it
right that's what you do your accountant
handles it for you so this is this is
sort of the problem the the Republican
Congress does not know how to do a
Public Relation blitz president Trump
does but he hasn't done it yet
I wish they'd been doing it for the last
month they should do it now the fact
they had to rush it through is going to
be picked on by the media and now every
piece of fallout from this bill it's
going to be used to Club Republicans to
death over it so Republicans had better
shaped this thing in the public
imagination right now not just wait for
the inevitable time when Americans
realize tax cuts are good that would be
that I think would be a very big mistake
again if you look at the polls on down
on tax cuts historically then what you
see is that the Bush tax cuts were were
significantly more popular than the
Trump tax cuts part of that is because
of Trump part of that is because of the
media coverage in fact these tax cuts
because of the media coverage are
actually less popular then some tax
hikes have been okay so here is the the
good rundown on the polling numbers this
is from five thirty eight.com the Reagan
tax cut in 1981 had a twenty five
percent plus twenty five percent
differential 51 percent approved twenty
six percent no the 2001 W tax cut twelve
percent plus 12 right forty nine to
thirty seven the extension of the Bush
tax cut in 2010 had a twelve percent
positive upside fifty-four percent
approved the extension of the Bush tax
cuts to in 2013 that had a seven percent
net positive rating the Bush tax cuts
too right in 2003 that had a six percent
positive rating the Reagan tax cuts too
in 1986 that had a four percent positive
rating the Clinton tax hikes of 93 had a
negative 10 percent rating forty four
percent
proved only 34% approved the HW Bush tax
hike had a negative 11 percent approval
rating so 52 to 41 disapproved and the
Trump tax cuts are 14% underwater that
is largely because of the media it is
also because the Republicans have done a
piss-poor job of selling their bill they
need to get out there and they need to
sell that bill because bills don't get
more popular over time even when people
feel the benefit of it Democrats will
pay by the way when they try to raise
the taxes but remember they're not gonna
have to actually try to do that until
2025 they can just sit there and and let
it go all the way till 2025 and then
wait to see what happens okay so as we
continue in just second I'm going to
talk about the media bias and how the
media bias plays in because it really is
truly astonishing I want to show you
some clips of members of the media and
how they have responded to these tax
cuts it is beyond the pale so here we go
let's begin with Savannah Guthrie so
Savannah Guthrie over at NBC News she
was questioning Paul she was questioning
Paul Ryan and Ryan is talking about tax
cuts and what kind of good they're going
to do and Savannah Guthrie literally
asked him if he is living in a fantasy
world on national television after they
passed a massive Republican tax plan a
problem is a lot of CEOs has said really
candidly I'm looking at a list of CEOs
who said we don't plan to reinvest what
they're planning to do is do stock
buybacks to line the pockets of
shareholders let me quote Michael
Bloomberg a billionaire hardly an enemy
of business
he said CEOs aren't waiting on a tax cut
to jumpstart the economy a favorite
phrase of politicians who have never run
a company or to hand out raises it's
pure fantasy to think that the tax bill
will lead to significantly higher wages
and growth I'll ask you plainly are you
living in a fantasy world and what the
hell kind of question is that are you
living in a fantasy world and what what
is wrong with you
Haywood they asked what they asked Obama
this did they ever ask Jonathan Gruber
this or Obama during Obamacare you said
that if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor every doctor in America
says that's not true
every single one pretty much are you
living in a fantasy world was that ever
asked I mean you want to see media bias
in action that right there is media bias
in action then you wonder why the
American people have a bad opinion of
the bill it's because of people like
Savannah Guthrie who are doing the job
that the Democrats have been attempting
to do for years and Savannah Guthrie
isn't the only one
Katy tur in the in the aftermath of the
Republicans voting to to pass the bill
she is talking with a with a GOP
representative and she throws out the
suggestion that the reason that
Republicans are passing this thing is
that they can pay less personally intact
she's talking to Dave brat the
Republican from Virginia the the tea
partier extraordinaire and here is Katy
tur going after him and suggesting that
it's just because he is these rich that
he wants to pay it what's the median
household income of your district it's
right about sixty we have it at seventy
three thousand something around there
whoa what are what are you making if you
don't mind what's in your bank account
right now in my bank account what tax
bracket are you are you gonna be under
under this bill well a court for you
here I'll be probably in the twenty four
percent bracket twenty can go look up
their rates okay
Republican congressman David what are
you what are you at Katie so make sure
you do not a lawmaker so I'm not
involved in marking up this little
selling it to the American people well
what you got what you're making to Kato
good good for Dave brat right there
because the fact is that when they asked
they have brat he's lowering his own
taxes that's why he's doing this thing
and it's not a principal thing it's just
the entire premise of the question is so
sick and messed up the entire premise of
the question that she is asking right
there is the only reason that you would
want taxes decreases not because you
think it's better for the American
people or your constituents or the
economy it's because you personally are
seeking to benefit from the tax bill
right but all those Democrats who are
rich they're just men of the people
they're just patriotic those are great
patrons Michael Bloomberg great Patriot
but you Dave brat you are a cruel
inhumane man because if you make a lot
of money that means you don't care about
people I was for tax cuts when I was
making sixty grand a year and I'm for
tax cuts when I make a hell of a lot
more than sixty thousand dollars a year
I was for tax cuts when I wasn't earning
anything and I was a student because
ideologically speaking speaking just
based on my understanding of economics
tax cuts generate more revenue by
putting more money in my pocket that I
can spend as I see fit beyond that I'm
for tax cuts because it's my money and
it's your money and I don't have a right
to your money but this implication is
being put forward by the media the
Republicans aren't like
it's only doing this because he wants a
tax cut are you freaking kidding me
Donald Trump is worth billions of
dollars even if you don't believe is
worth 10 billion he's probably worth at
least two okay you think Donald Trump is
sitting there right now thinking to
himself yeah you know I really need to
give myself a tax cut that's top of my
priority list is giving myself a tax cut
are you crazy
are you out of your mind all these
Republican legislators they're sitting
around thinking yeah you know what by
the way if you want to get rich in
Congress the easiest way to get rich in
Congress is not giving yourself a tax
cut the easiest way to get rich in
Congress is through insider trading it's
by knowing which bills are gonna pass
and then you buy stock in particular
companies knowing how the bills gonna
impact that company Peter Schweitzer
showed this in in one of his books a few
years back where he talked about
corruption in DC this notion that that
Republican legislators are only doing
this because they're so evil is just
absurd by the way I'll bet you Katie
turns making a lot more money than a
brat if I had to bet on it I mean the
Dave brand I believe was a college
professor if he's in the 24 percent tax
bracket that means he's not making I
mean he he's making decent money I think
but but the idea that he's making all
sorts of cash is not actually is not
actually the case so I'm gonna you know
I want to look that up because I would
guarantee you the Katy tour is making a
lot more money than Dave Brad so yeah if
Dave Brad is in the twenty four percent
bracket that means he's making between
$82,000 $157,000 right if he's in that
bracket by the way then that means that
he's probably only saving three four
thousand bucks okay he's not saving
fifty grand
Katy tur I I I'll have to look up Katy
turns contract let's see if she's paid
millions I'll bet I'll bet Katy tur
makes a lot of money I'll bet I'll bet
that she she makes three times easily
what Dave brad is making if not then she
then she needs to renegotiate her
contract so that's that's absurd and you
sing this across the board this media
coverage they NBC MSNBC gave airtime to
a health care activist what did this
health care activist who was battling
ALS and he waited outside Lindsey
Graham's office in order to yell at
Lindsey Graham over this because Lindsey
Graham and the Republicans voted to get
rid of the individual mandate the most
unpopular aspect of the of Obamacare and
so they put him on MSNBC they talked
about Lindsey Graham ran away from him
as a sinner Graham he was talking about
John McCain his beloved colleague who
like me
dying of a brain disease and he was
talking about John McCain and I said
Senator Graham will talk to me for a
minute about this bill and he ran away
into a place where I'm not allowed to go
as a civilian I know that NBC and MSNBC
have footage of that you could try to
find it he ran away and that exemplifies
that moment I was there with Megan
Anderson a woman is almost totally
paralyzed that moment exemplified our
publicans are treating this legislation
and treating the American people they
are afraid to see our humanity and okay
nonsense this is it again a cheap media
setup okay I objected to it when Piers
Morgan's in and on gun control and I
object to it now the idea that your
philosophy of governance has to change
because you are now meeting somebody who
is suffering from particular condition
is just asinine it's just not true it's
the say it's in effect the same thing as
Jimmy Kimmel taking his baby out every
so often and holding up his baby and
saying that he knows about health care
now policy is either good or bad it is
not good based on whether you can have a
discussion in front of cameras with a
guy who has ALS and an agenda
I feel awful for that person of course
you feel awful for people that doesn't
mean that the policy they're espousing
is bad and you know how that exchange is
gonna go by the way the way that
exchange is going to go is that Lindsey
Graham will walk up to the guy have a
cordial conversation the guy will refuse
to hear what Lindsey Graham is saying
because he comes with an agenda he's not
there for an honest conversation he's
there for the photo-op and then when
Lindsey Graham says you know it's been
nice talking to you and the guy who
refuses to shake his hand because
Lindsey Graham has is voting for
something the guy doesn't want the media
blow it up oh the this watch this
courageous man suffering from ALS take
Lindsey Graham to the woodshed if I have
our Lindsey Graham I wouldn't engage in
that conversation either because it's
not worth it right where is it where's
the public relations upside and where's
the win you're not even having an honest
conversation it's not like this guy
actually wants to discuss with Lindsey
Graham he wants Alexa Lindsey Graham but
this is the game the media are playing
today so just like the homeless reappear
every eight years when a Republican
takes office it's like Groundhog Day
every so often the homeless just pop up
on your screen and that only happens
when Republicans are in the White House
so the same thing happens with regard to
taxes we never talk about tax increases
and how they're gonna
the American people we never talk about
government spending and deficits and how
they're gonna hurt the American people
we only talk about these things when it
comes to Republicans and that's only so
that the media can carry out their their
crusade against tax cuts altogether
which is just it's pathetic now will
Trump benefit from this you know this
does change the man I got an email
yesterday from from somebody who's
asking me you know you graded Trump last
week and he gave him an overall grade
for his presidency of like a c-minus it
must have been I think that's probably a
couple of weeks ago nothing was last
week it's probably a couple of weeks ago
and and I given him an overall grade of
C - based on his policy and his rhetoric
and he said you've been pretty glowing
about him in the last couple of weeks
and the answer is yes because I'm
getting the things I want right that was
always my math my math was always is the
president doing conservative things the
last three weeks of president Trump's
governance have been some of the most
conservative weeks of Governments that I
have ever seen period from any president
I'm pretty young so the last Republican
administration I remember was Bush he
was not as conservative as Trump has
been in the last three weeks for sure
and so this has been a very good three
weeks of governance it's very important
governance - so that means that I raised
Trump's grade from a c-minus on the year
to a C+ which is a pretty major chef for
anything that shifts him almost a full
letter grade in the last three weeks of
year the only reason that he's not doing
better than that is because his approval
ratings are bad because Republicans are
running really far behind in the generic
congressional ballot they're out yeah
they're down 18 points in the latest
poll one of the one of the things that
Trump has to do here as they spoke about
the other day it's very important now
that now that Trump is actually pursuing
conservative policies you represent
conservatism well because otherwise all
of those conservative policies will be
rolled back it's very important that he
represents my view well right now he's a
representative of my ideology when he's
actually acting in consonance with my
ideology I want to see him represent
that ideology well just as an American I
want you know it's like watching the
Olympics you want to see people wearing
the American flag do well Trump is now
wearing the conservative flag and has
been for at least the last three weeks
on governance and that means that I want
to see him represent that well do well
in the polls because of it I want I want
to see conservative governance become
more popular not less popular I don't
want his personal and popularity to drag
down the good policy he's been making I
would like to see his popularity
increase on the back of that good policy
and that means some discipline so mr.
president if you're listening please
have some discipline
messaging I think that you've won some
major victories even the media are gonna
have to recognize that you've had a
major upswing in the last month of your
presidency with regard to policy wins
you have some momentum going into next
year do not get distracted it's the
holiday season celebrate it with your
family shut down your Twitter for
Christmas shut it down for the next
three weeks make the left go mad
make them go mad right starve them of
your tweets if the left are waiting for
you to give them some distraction from
the loss they just suffered they're
waiting for an excuse to go off on you
they're waiting for an excuse to go
crazy don't watch TV turn off your TV
have yourself a Shabbos ready have
yourself a Shabbat all right one of the
things that's nice about my life is that
every Friday evening to Saturday evening
I just shut down right there's there's
no cell phone there's no internet
there's no TV and it's great you deserve
a rest mr. president is what I'm saying
to you I mean I wish that your deserved
rest on sort of the entire year but now
you really do deserve a rest because you
gotten some stuff done bask in the glow
of having a major piece of legislation
passed let the media feed on itself let
the media eat itself let the media
fulminate over what is a very typical
Republican tax bill let them look
foolish let them stew in their own
juices you have the upper hand right now
don't blow it
don't blow it because now there's
actually there's that and here's the
thing Republicans are more likely to
follow you mr. president if you don't
blow it and if you if you actually start
to boost your own approval ratings
Republicans are more likely to come
around on some of your other policy
priorities like immigration and please
for the love of God don't don't try to
tackle daca that would be a mistake okay
we're gonna continue in just a second
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wired.com and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can become a
subscriber to daily Wired icon you get
the rest of my show live on video you
get the rest of mandrill Clavin the show
live on video yet the rest of Michael
moles is show live on video you got all
of these wonderful things plus you get
to be part of the mailbag I thought it
was Thursday sadly it is not that's
Friday is the mailbag so Friday we'll be
doing the mailbag you get to be part of
that live and when we have our
conversations our Q&A s then you get to
be part of that mailbag too you log into
daily wire you go over to the the live
chat window you ask questions we read
them right off so you gets to do that
which is pretty cool and Shapiro store
is coming in the new year I know I've
been promising that for a year but it's
actually gonna happen like presidents
Trump president say it's gonna get
started with the good stuff soon so
Chaparro store is is going to be
happening so check that out if you want
the annual subscription you
all of those glories for $99 a year plus
you also get this giveaway you left this
Cheers hot or cold tumbler this will
make your Christmas or Hanukkah complete
today's the last day of Konica so if you
want to buy some belated Hanukkah gift
to it
Christmas has not yet happen so make
sure that you go and put this under
somebody's tree with eight with a free
with a free tumbler with your your gift
subscription to your family and friends
so check that out or listen later on
Soundcloud or iTunes we have a big
YouTube video a Christmas YouTube video
coming out in the next 24 to 48 hours
you won't want to see that so subscribe
to our youtube channel as well we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty time for some things I like
some things I hate and then we will do a
little bit of Bible talk so things I
like yesterday I did gunfight at the OK
Corral and today I'm going to do another
movie with a signature tune and this and
I think I'm gonna try and stick to
westerns with signature Tunes but this
is the this is High Noon of course this
is Bill Clinton's favorite movie a lot
of a lot of people on the right objected
to this being Bill Clinton's favorite
movie because the entire plot surrounds
a sheriff who is basically left alone by
the town to defend the town against a
bad guy and a lot of conservatives said
well that's really not how towns work
right that's actually if Clinton viewed
himself as the lone hero striding into
history that's not good for the
presidency the movie however is quite
good Gary Cooper plays the sheriff
Grace Kelly plays the the woman in his
life who is a she's a Quaker I believe
and she refuses to participate in
violence the movie is is pretty
compelling
it's very small-scale it is very tightly
edited and tightly crafted I heard a
little bit of preview
it's Gary Cooper a man who is too proud
to run the judges left town Harvey's
quit and I'm having trouble getting
deputy people gotta talk themselves into
law and order before they do anything
about it
maybe because down deep they don't care
they just don't care I think you better
go while there's still time it's better
for you and it's better for us Amy I
mean if you won't go with me now I'll be
on that train when it leaves you I've
got to stay why must you be so stupid
what if you've forgotten what he is if
he forgotten what he's done to people
who've had forgotten that he's crazy
don't you remember when he sat in that
chair and said song isn't the title song
is very famous of course you know do not
forsake me oh my darlin it's very very
famous in Western history a High Noon
great movie worth watching check that
out over the weekend if you have time
okay other things that I like I have I'm
have to admit I cannot stop laughing at
the fact that Tana he see coats and
Cornel West are now going at it
Cornel West of course a radical black
activist Tony he's he goes to slightly
less radical black activist Tony he's he
coats fancies himself in the mold of
James Baldwin Cornel West fancies
himself in the mold of Malcolm X both of
them are both of them have a rather
racially separatist view of American
politics and Cornel West wrote an entire
column where he says Tony he see coaches
we were eight years in power a book
about Barack Obama's presidency and the
tenacity of white supremacy has captured
the attention of many of us he says
Coates and I come from a great tradition
of the black freedom struggle he
represents the neoliberal wing that
sounds militants about white supremacy
but renders black fightback invisible
this wing reaps the benefits of the
neoliberal establishment that rewards
silences on issues such as Wall Street
greed or Israeli occupation of
Palestinian lands and people's he says
the disagreement between coaching me is
clear any analysis or vision of our
world that omits the centrality of Wall
Street power u.s. military policies and
the complex dynamics of class gender and
sexuality in black America is too narrow
and dangerously misleading so it is with
Donaghy seed coats his worldview
he says Coates rightly highlights the
vicious legacy of white supremacy past
and president
past and present he sees it everywhere
and everyone and ever reminds us of its
plundering effects unfortunately he
hardly keeps track of our fight back and
never connects this ugly legacy to the
predatory capitalist practices Imperial
policies or the black elites refusal to
confront poverty patriarchy or
transphobia in short coats fetishizes
white supremacy he makes it all mighty
magical and unremovable so this is kind
of hilarious
taani he see Coates is now being ripped
by Cornel West and Richard Spencer the
white supremacist is agreeing with
Cornel West against Tony he's he coats
and now Tony he's he coats has suspended
his he has suspended his Twitter account
in response to all of this Cornel West
is not wrong by the way that quote that
that on t he C code sees white supremacy
hiding under the bed it's just the
Cornel West is even more of a Marxist
and then he is a racial conflict so
watching these sorts of in fights is
entertaining to say the least because
both of them are wrong just in in
slightly different ways
other things that I like so I just had
to laugh at this so President Trump is
now been entered into Disney's Hall of
Presidents and let's just say it is not
good it does not look my President Trump
do you have any video
[Music]
by Donald John Trump do solemnly swear
that I will faithfully execute the
office of President of the United States
okay
that is that look at that picture of
Donald John Trump look just in the face
forget the hair whose face is that
that's Hillary Clinton's face it really
looks a lot as though Disney made this
doll of Hillary Clinton turn it male it
does look at anything like Trump I mean
it said this one goes in the you know I
I have a great love for bad sculpture
and this one goes in the bad sculpture
Hall of Fame so well done Disney putting
Donald Trump in the Hall of Presidents
is in and of itself highly entertaining
that's pretty spectacular okay time for
a quick thing that I hate CNN's Chris
Cuomo who he's got to be the thickest
guy on cable TV and that's saying a lot
there are a lot of thick people on cable
TV and I don't mean that isn't like the
the rap sexy thing I mean like dumb
Chris Cuomo Chris Cuomo was criticizing
president Trump's drinking technique
like this is what we've come to now the
president from throwing a speech he
reaches over he picks up his glass of
water he doesn't a weird way is gonna
pick up the glass and drink it he takes
it with both hands kind of sips it and
then puts it back down and this turns
into a four-minute segment on CNN the
president reached for a glass of water
during his national security speech and
Twitter took note it has led to
comparisons of how the president needs
to use two hands apparently to drink
from a water bottle he did that during
the speech last month and then again
yesterday the water works with the
president started the waterworks started
with the campaign of course when he
poked fun at Senator Marco Rubio for
pausing mid-sentence for some water but
this wasn't even smaller glass yesterday
where he used two hands I believe last
time you called it the baby grip well
that is the sippy cup grip that you're
using there right now it is a very good
I don't get all the hands thing in the
glass you know I don't I don't know what
it's all about it this is what I drink
out I drink out of them and I hold it
like a man with one hand but that's you
know that's that's me right that's
and I'm just a giant certainly not one
of us this concerns you want to hold the
cup with all your hands you don't you
that's what you do what a sippy cup grip
so there's a and then you wonder why
Trump's those fake news all the time
this is wise from sis fake news not
because its faith that that's a weird
way to grip a cup but because like why
is this on the news at all maybe the
Twitter is a funny place and there's
lots of funny stuff on Twitter I engage
in it on a regular basis but um I'm not
really certain that this is appropriate
CNN commentary okay finally let's do a
little bit of Bible talk so there's a
lot of talk from the left today about
how it is unbiblical it is just terrible
that we are not talking about
centralizing government centralized
government is is is dedicating like God
wants government to create that the
tendency for fairness so this is a
section from the book of Judges I
believe this chapter 8 of the book of
Judges and talks about the rule of
Gideon so Gideon was of course a prophet
in Israel and he leads his men in a
fight against the Philistines and other
groups that are that are oppressing the
Israelites and here's what it says it
says then the men of Israel said to
Gideon rule over us both you and your
son also your son son for you have saved
us from the hand of Midian and Gideon
said to them I shall not rule over you
and my son will not rule over you the
Lord will rule over you right which is a
pretty astonishing statement the Bible
is at best ambivalent about monarchy
like really ambivalent about monarchy
Moses warns that it's not going to be
good Samuel Schmo it warns in in 1
Samuel 1st Samuel we called Schmoe olive
in Hebrew which is why I hesitate on the
English translation in in shuo if Samuel
gives an entire lecture to the people
about why it's gonna suck once they
point to King now you have this in the
book of Judges where Gideon says rule
yourselves basically don't have a
centralized government that rules over
you the idea of a theocratic government
that is centralized from the very top is
not really well spelled out in in the
Old Testament at all and it's not
spelled out well in the New Testament
either I mean the idea of render unto
Caesar in the New Testament is very much
reflective of the basic Jewish idea of
Dina DeMarco sadena which literally
means the law of the land is the law and
insofar as it doesn't conflicted the law
of God you have to obey it what's
fascinating about this section with
regard to Gideon is not just that he
says that he's not going to rule over
the people that they have to rule
themselves that God is gonna rule over
them he says I would make a request of
you that you give me every man the nose
ring of his spoil for they had to go
nose-rings because they were Ishmaelites
and they said we shall willingly give
and they spread out the garment and
every man there in through the nose ring
of his spoil and then gideon takes all
of these rings and then he makes in a
phone which is a breastplate and he said
it's his up in his home city and it says
then all israel went astray after it
there and it became a snare to gideon
into his house the importance of this
the reason this matters is when a group
of people decide to collectively pool
their labor and make something you have
to be very careful they don't begin to
worship the thing that they make and
this is true of the american government
we're very proud of our of our
government we're very proud of our
system of government we're proud of
washington DC the big buildings and how
pretty it is in all of us but it's very
easy for us to start worshipping the
thing that we have made with our own
hands and to suggest that it has some
sort of outsized power even though we
are the ones that made it and to suggest
that people in the future need to throw
their knows rings into the into the pot
as well that's not the way the American
government was meant to be built it's
not the way that that it even was in the
Bible there's a reason the Bible says
that this becomes a snare to the leaders
it becomes a snare to the people
collective collective action must be
taken from time to time but the key
there is from time to time ok we'll be
back here tomorrow with more notes on
all the fallout and ben shapiro there's
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jess
while opera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017